À Castelnaudary,
Dans le sud ouest de la France,
Bienvenue à la Légion étrangère.
Quatrième section, rassemblez.
3 sous officiers, 5 caporaux chefs composeront l'encadrement.
56 engagés volontaires.
À vos ordres mon adjudant.
Ces 56 hommes sont la nouvelle promotion du corps d'élite.
Sélectionnés après plusieurs étapes, leur formation va durer 4 mois.
Vous vous êtes portés volontaires pour la Légion étrangère,
Vous vous êtes présentés à Aubagne,
Vous avez été sélectionné.
Vous avez choisi la difficulté.
Maintenant, il va falloir assumer votre choix.
On n'est pas venu vous chercher,
Vous êtes venu de vous même ici, à la Légion étrangère.
À vous de montrer que vous êtes dignes de devenir légionnaires.
Ils viennent du monde entier pour servir dans l'armée française.
Qui sont-ils exactement ?
Quelle est leur histoire ?
Quelles raisons les poussent à tirer un trait sur le passé ?
Jusqu'à changer d'identité.
Je suis en train d'inventer une nouvelle signature,
Vu que j'ai changé de nom.
Changement d'identité et discipline la plus stricte.
Ok, vous vous déshabillez, vous enlevez tout.
Vous restez nu.
Strip-tease total.
Ils disent au revoir à leur vie civile, c'est tout !
Une nouvelle vie, un nouveau visage.
Au programme, des épreuves physiques intenses.
Tous, ne tiendront pas le choc.
Je pensais y arriver et en fait, c'est trop pour moi.
L'adjudant Stéphane est le chef des instructeurs.
Qui parle peu, à peu à répondre.
C'est ça ?
Mais ça ne marche pas comme ça !
Pas bon, pas bon, pas bon !
On va rafraîchi un peu la volonté là.
Sous ses ordres, aucun manquement n'est toléré.
À chaque écart, une sanction.
Je veux pas voir quelqu'un qui se masturbe quelque part,
Avec les pieds, avec les bras.
Préparez-vous !
Au fil des semaines, les candidats à la Légion apprennent le métier.
Des épreuves de plus en plus difficiles,
Et des entraînements plus vrais que nature.
Toujours regarder les zones, toujours avec votre camarade.
Et si l'ennemi arrive, toi t'es dans la merde.
T'as compris ?
Et pour finir en beauté, cette formation éprouvante,
Une marche de 60 kilomètres en montagne,
Avec 30 kilos sur le dos et l'arme toujours en bandoulière.
Pour certains, l'épreuve sera un véritable enfer.
Je ne m'attendais pas à ça, vraiment !
Je croyais que j'étais capable.
C'est de plus en plus dur.
Pour que ça reste un souvenir,
Tu dois avoir de la douleur et un beau paysage.
Bah là, t'as les deux.
Donc tu vas jusqu'au bout !
C'est clair ?
Ne jamais rien lâcher pour décrocher le précieux sésame.
Le képi blanc de la Légion étrangère.
Le trophée qui signe leur entrée dans ce corps d'exception.
Coiffez votre képi.
Ne sont retenus que les meilleurs,
Avant d'y parvenir,
Ils en auront bavé pendant 4 mois.
L'aventure de tous légionnaires commence à Nogent-sur-Marne,
À quelques kilomètres de Paris.
Dans cette caserne débute un long processus de sélection.
Pour mener à bien cette mission une centaine d'encadrants.
Ils effectuent un premier tri des recrues,
Qui franchissent les grilles du fort de Nogent.
Chaque jour, une vingtaine de volontaires,
Tentent leur chance,
Avec un seul rêve en tête.
Faire partie de la grande famille de la Légion.
Bonjour!
J'aimerais m'engager à la Légion.
Nationalité ?
Gabonaise.
Est-ce que vous avez des affaires pour la toilette ?
Oui, j'ai regardé le site internet,
J'ai pris une paire de claquettes, trois caleçons,
Trois T-shirt, une brosse à dents, du matériel pour la douche.
Ici, pour être candidat,
Il suffit de peu de choses matérielles.
Mais mieux vaut être motivé.
S'engager, c'est changer radicalement de vie.
À 21 ans Stan, on en est bien conscient.
Ça fait quelque chose.
C'est à dire, on se lève un matin, on se dit :
"Moi, je vais à la légion étrangère".
J'ai appelé toute ma famille,
Je les ai avertis, je leur ai dit :.
"Je vais aller à la Légion étrangère !"
Et que pendant 5 ans,
Ils risquent de ne pas avoir de nouvelles précises de moi.
Et je suis venu direct.
Stan, le Gabonais,
N'est pas le seul à tenter sa chance ce matin.
Au même moment, un Espagnol, un Algérien et un Brésilien,
Se présentent au fort de no Nogent.
Unique en son genre,
La Légion étrangère est réputée dans le monde entier.
Chaque année, 8000 hommes venus de tout pays,
Viennent frapper à sa porte.
C'est à partir de maintenant que les épreuves vont se succéder pour ces nouvelles recrues.
Tu poses ton sac là. Bien sur la ligne !
Débute un véritable parcours du combattant.
En moyenne, la Légion incorpore qu'un candidat sur huit.
Maintenant, vous allez faire les tractions.
Il faut en faire le maximum.
Premiers test éliminatoire,
Les tractions,
Exercice efficace qui permet déjà au recruteur,
De remarquer les bons éléments.
C'est le cas de Stan.
Lui, on voit que c'est bon sportif.
Il a un bon potentiel physique.
Au fort de Nogent,
La sélection n'en est qu'à ses débuts.
Avant les prochaines échéances,
Les candidats ont intérêt à se maintenir en forme.
De leur propre initiative,
Les exercices physiques s'enchaînent.
Stan, le Gabonais,
Paraît particulièrement impliqué et motive les troupes.
Il faut, il faut, il faut !
Il faut le faire, on est tous ensemble !
Il faut s'aider !
On est tous dans le même bateau.
Un esprit de corps est en train de naître,
Même si les candidats viennent d'horizons très différents.
À l'image de Kovick.
Pour ce jeune Ukrainien,
Un changement de vie radical motivé par des raisons économiques.
En Ukraine, je suis professeur d'histoire.
Mais bon, là-bas, ce n'est pas un très bon métier.
On ne gagne pas beaucoup d'argent, à peine 100€ par mois.
C'est pour ça que je rêve de rejoindre la Légion et devenir un soldat.
En Ukraine, ce n'est pas possible.
Si Kovick parvient à devenir légionnaire,
Il commencera avec un salaire de 1 280€ par mois.
À la caserne, le défilé des candidats est sans fin.
Nouvel arrivant, Swann.
Il vient d'Écosse.
En général, les engagés ne s'épanchent pas sur les raisons,
Qui les poussent à vouloir intégrer la Légion.
Fait rare, Swann, nous raconte son histoire,
Avec beaucoup d'émotion.
Ça fait très longtemps que j'y pense,
Mais là, je veux vraiment, vraiment y entrer !
C'est ma dernière chance.
La dernière chance d'avoir une vie saine.
Je n'ai nulle part où aller.
Vous savez, j'ai un casier judiciaire.
J'ai des enfants à charge.
Je ne les vois pas souvent.
J'ai besoin d'une cause à laquelle m'accrocher.
Quelque chose qui me change profondément.
Je veux faire quelque chose de bien,
Je veux pouvoir être à nouveau fier de moi.
Comme Swann,
Beaucoup de candidats espèrent rentrer à la Légion étrangère,
Pour réparer des erreurs ou des échecs passés.
C'est aussi le cas de Shirt, un Hollandais de 34 ans,
Arrivé il y a quelques jours.
Comme Swann, il espère que la Légion lui donnera une seconde chance dans la vie.
Viens avec moi. Tu t'appelles ?
Swann.
Et tu viens d'où ?
D'Écosse.
Guidé par Shirt,
Swann découvre son nouvel univers.
Un dortoir de 20 lits.
Choisis ton lit.
Tu as le choix entre celui-ci et celui-là.
Je vais prendre celui-là.
Shirt n'est là que depuis 10 jours.
Mais l'Écossais, lui obéit au doigt et à l'oeil.
Il enfile sa nouvelle tenue,
Qu'il portera tout au long de son séjour à Nogent.
Pas encore d'uniforme militaire, mais un survêtement.
Les gars arrivent très rapidement et tous les jours,
On a besoin de leur expliquer les règles à suivre.
Comment faire son lit, quel type de vêtements.
Mes chaussures, je les mets au bout du lit ?
Tu peux les poser à gauche.
Des règles de vie déjà très strictes,
C'est le prix à payer pour espérer rejoindre la Légion.
Comme Swann, Shirt veut tourner la page d'une vie cabossée.
Ma motivation, c'est de pouvoir donner du sens à ma vie.
J'ai fait quand même pas mal de conneries dans le passé.
J'ai été en prison, ils m'ont relâché récemment.
Et maintenant, je veux faire quelque chose de bien,
Quelque chose dont je sois fière.
Le passé de Shirt,
Lui permettra t-il d'aller au bout de l'aventure ?
En attendant, il enseigne les fondamentaux à Swann.
Comme par exemple faire son lit de façon impeccable,
Le fameux lit au carré.
Un avant goût d'une vie réglée au millimètre.
Merci mec.
Mais le chemin est encore long.
Deuxième étape décisive pour les candidats,
Un interrogatoire poussé.
Ok les gars, levez-vous et suivez moi.
Ici, rien n'est laissé au hasard.
Le passé de chaque candidat est examiné à la loupe.
C'est au tour de Shirt d'être soumis à l'interrogatoire.
La Légion tolère certains démêlés avec la justice,
Mais pour le Hollandais, son passé risque d'être trop lourd.
Est-ce que tu as des problèmes avec la police ?
J'ai eu des problèmes avec la police, oui.
J'ai été arrêté pour trafic de drogue international.
Je ne peux pas retourner chez moi en Hollande.
J'ai dû rompre tout lien avec ma famille,
Pour les mettre en sécurité.
C'était trop dangereux.
J'ai tout perdu.
Et aujourd'hui, quelle est ta situation avec la justice ?
Ça va, maintenant j'ai payé ma dette.
Les problèmes de Shirt avec la justice sont derrière lui,
Mais des criminels hollandais sont à sa recherche.
Il espère que la Légion pourra le protéger,
Et ne tiendra pas compte de son passé sulfureux.
Je vais juste marquer tout ça.
Il y a un département qui s'occupe de tout ça,
Le niveau de sécurité et tout ça.
Ils vont bien vérifier que tout ce qu'il nous a dit est vrai.
Le fait qu'il ait du courage,
Ça montre qu'il a envie de faire autre chose,
De passer à autre chose.
S'il parvenait à intégrer la légion,
Shirt pourrait repartir de zéro.
Il serait protégé par une nouvelle identité.
À partir de maintenant, les candidats doivent oublier leur passé.
Comme pour Stan, le Gabonais,
La Légion leur invente une nouvelle histoire personnelle.
Lis d'abord ok ?
Dès que tu sors d'ici, c'est ta nouvelle identité, Apanga.
Si le caporal chef dit Apanga, c'est bien toi.
Ok ? APanga, c'est toi.
Nom de famille APanga, prénom Philippe.
Qu'est-ce que ça fait d'avoir une nouvelle identité ?
Ça fait un peu mystérieux.
Ça remonte, ça fait un peu mystérieux.
C'est pas tout le monde qui peut changer d'identité comme il veut.
Et c'est justement ça qui m'intéresse,
Parce que je suis un peu, on va dire on est différent,
c'est un peu exceptionnel.
Tout est clair ?
T'as tout compris ?
Oui Caporal Chef.
Là n'oublies pas ta nouvelle identité.
À partir de maintenant on va t'appeler Apanga !
Oui Caporal chef.
Si le candidat ne nous plaît pas,
S'il ne remplit pas des conditions,
Ce que nous on exige,
Il peut être refoulé !
Il ne sera pas pris, tout simplement.
Si on voit qu'il a un profil intéressant, il continue la route.
Changer d'identité,
C'est l'une des traditions de la Légion.
Stan devient Philippe,
Swann, Robert et Shirt, Tony.
Mais pour les candidats, à ce stade là, rien n'est encore joué.
Au fil des jours, la tension est de plus en plus palpable.
Les candidats sont maintenant soumis à toute une batterie d'examens médicaux.
Le moindre problème de santé est synonyme d'exclusion immédiate.
À l'issue des tests, le verdict tombe.
Ce ne sera pas bon pour toi,
Monte voir le Caporal chef pour qu'il t'explique tout.
Et sors d'ici maintenant.
Ok, merci Monsieur.
Bonne chance.
Shirt est recalé.
Ses rêves d'une nouvelle vie s'envole.
J'ai voulu jouer cartes sur table et tout dire de mon passé,
Malheureusement, ça n'a pas suffit.
C'est la vie.
Le moral des troupes en prend un coup.
Ses nouveaux amis sont sous le choc.
Shirt ne recevra aucune explication quant à son élimination.
Mais il a sa petite idée sur la question.
C'est sûr, c'est à cause de mon passé.
Swann, l'ecossais essaie de soutenir comme il peut,
Celui qui l'a guidé à son arrivée.
Je suis désolé pour toi mec.
J'ai perdu 6 mois pour ça.
Tout ça pour rien !
J'ai nulle part où aller et je n'ai pas d'argent.
J'ai tout misé sur ce coup là.
Tu as de l'argent sur toi ?
J'ai rien.
Peut-être que tu peux prendre mes 5 derniers euros, je m'en fous.
Tu peux aussi avoir mon fric.
Moi j'ai 20€.
Ça serait super, merci les gars.
Ça ne me pose pas de souci.
Vraiment aucun.
Merci. Bonne chance.
À la Légion, pas le temps de s'émouvoir.
Une épreuve d'endurance attend les candidats restants.
Un test qui, à première vue, paraît simple.
Swann, l'Ecossais,
N'a pas encore réalisé que ce qui ressemble à une promenade de santé,
Est en réalité un exercice redoutable.
On va bientôt passer à la prochaine étape.
J'espère que mon âge ne va pas me poser de problème.
Mais je ne pense pas, je suis confiant !
Je suis même impatient plutôt que nerveux.
Trois, deux, un. C'est parti !
Début du test.
But du jeu,
Courir pendant 8 minutes,
Entre 2 lignes espacées de 20 mètres chacune.
À chaque bip, le rythme s'accélère.
L'exercice s'avère vite délicat pour Swann.
Arrête toi là, sors d'ici !
Sérieux, sors d'ici, c'est fini !
Non, je continue.
Je ne peux pas abandonner.
Swann est arrêté sur le champ.
Il risque l'exclusion.
Je ne pouvais plus courir, tout simplement.
Je pensais y arriver, mais en fait, c'est trop pour moi.
Son avenir de légionnaire ne tient plus qu'à un fil.
Allez, allez, allez, allez !
Pour le numéro huit,
Après, un deuxième avertissement,
On est obligé de le faire sortir,
Parce qu'il n'était plus capable de franchir la ligne d'arrivée et la ligne de départ.
La dernière chance de survie pour Swann,
C'est de réussir l'épreuve suivante,
Les fameuses tractions.
Il doit en faire un maximum pour rester en course.
Mais après 9 mouvements,
L'Ecossais n'a plus aucune force dans les bras.
Je suis super déçu de moi.
On verra bien.
Mais je ne peux pas sortir aujourd'hui, c'est pas possible.
Pour Swann, l'avenir est des plus incertain.
Ses neuf tractions vont-elles suffire à compenser son échec à la course ?
Stan, lui, n'a pas ce problème.
Encore une fois, il est très à l'aise.
24 Tractions.
Il pulvérise le record.
Sous les applaudissements de ses camarades.
Ce qui est très mal vu par l'instructeur.
La prochaine fois que vous faites ça, vous dégagez.
Vous vous croyez où là ? Au spectacle ?
Aller, là-bas.
Pour Stan, mission accomplie.
Il a passé les épreuves haut la main.
Je ne pouvais pas lâcher l'affaire,
Je pouvais tenir jusqu'à ce que mon corps ne donne plus.
C'était ça pour moi le plus important,
Donner tout ce que j'avais jusqu'à ce que mon corps,
Ne donne plus rien.
C'était le plus important pour moi.
Bien moins performant, Swann va bientôt être fixé sur son sort.
Son futur se joue en quelques minutes.
Dans un couloir.
Tes tests d'endurance sont vraiment très moyens.
Mais on va quand même te laisser continuer.
On a décidé de te donner une deuxième chance,
Mais il faut vraiment que tu y mette du tien.
Oui, je le ferais.
Je vais courir tous les jours,
2 fois par jour s'il le faut.
Pourquoi ça te touche autant ?
Parce que j'ai besoin de ça dans ma vie.
Si je ne le fais pas, je quitterai les lieux sans rien,
Si ce n'est un énorme sentiment d'échec.
Et partir d'ici,
Juste parce que je n'ai pas réussi à courir 2 minutes de plus,
C'est pas envisageable.
Je ne pourrais pas le supporter.
Le soir venu, dans la chambrée,
L'heure est à la détente.
Swann retrouve le sourire.
Il a récupéré de ses efforts,
Et surtout il a l'assurance de passer à l'étape suivante.
Après Nogent, la sélection pour les candidats retenus,
Va se poursuivre dans le sud de la France.
Ok extinction des feux.
À 5 h du matin, les 9 heureux élus du jour,
Prennent le bus pour la gare de Lyon.
À venir,
7h de train,
Pour gagner le centre d'incorporation d'Aubagne,
Où tout va se jouer pour eux.
À quelques kilomètres de Marseille, le quartier Vienot à Aubagne,
C'est le cœur de la Légion.
Messieurs, la mission est finie pour moi.
Je vais laisser vos passeports là-haut.
Et bonne chance à tous, c'est bon ?
L'encadrant, qui les accompagnait depuis Nogent,
Passe le relais à l'équipe d'Aubagne.
À partir de maintenant, l'ambiance va radicalement changer.
Seuls les meilleurs deviendront légionnaires.
Les 9 candidats sont tout de suite mis dans l'ambiance.
Ok, vous vous déshabillez, vous enlevez tout, vous restez nus.
Strip tease total.
Vous changez le slip.
Silence dans les rangs.
Plus aucune fantaisie n'est tolérée.
Ok là ils vont être changés.
Ils ne sont pas encore militaires, mais ils sont prêts pour être militaires.
Alors la sélection commence à ce moment.
Dès que je les change, après ils commencent à travailler,
Il va se passer pleins de choses.
Généralement en 12 semaines.
Soit ils sont choisis, soit non.
À Aubagne, jusqu'à la moitié des volontaires peut être recalé.
Sans être encore militaire,
Ils sont désormais soumis à la dure loi de l'école de la Légion.
Tout ce qui peut rappeler au candidat son passé est interdit,
Les objets personnels ou encore la monnaie de leur pays d'origine.
Maintenant vous sortez votre argent !
L'argent dans vos mains.
Seulement les euros.
Seulement votre argent.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils peuvent garder et ne pas garder ?
Que leur argent et leurs cigarettes.
Juste à l'entrée,
On sent tout de suite que ce n'est pas du tout la même chose.
Que ça devient vraiment un peu plus sérieux ici.
Pas que là-bas c'était pas sérieux,
Mais ça devient quelque chose de vraiment plus concret,
Et plus, comme je dis, quelque chose de plus rapide et plus perfectionné.
Vous ramassez toutes vos affaires,
Vous les rangez dans le sac et vous fermez le sac.
Dorénavant, tout lien avec le passé est rompu.
À la Légion, chaque engagé est un homme neuf.
Ils disent au revoir à leur vie civile, c'est tout !
Voici le centre des Renseignements généraux.
Derrière ces murs,
Chaque postulant est entendu par une dizaine d'interrogateurs,
En lien avec Interpol et les polices du monde.
Tout est passé au crible,
La puce du téléphone, les comptes en banque, les réseaux sociaux.
Les recrues découvrent qu'il est impossible,
De cacher quoi que ce soit à la Légion.
Les réactions des candidats sont observées avec soin,
Les réponses rigoureusement vérifiées.
Cet entretien si redouté,
Se déroule dans le secret le plus absolu.
Il nous est interdit de le filmer.
Après 2h d'interrogatoire, Stan livre ses impressions,
À une recrue qui n'est pas encore passée devant la commission.
Tu ne vas pas répondre complètement ouvertement.
Tu va essayer, tu ne vas pas forcément te justifier.
T'as vraiment, on va dire, un espace limité pour répondre.
Ça, déjà, ça joue beaucoup,
Du fait qu'on te pose une question,
Mais on ne demande pas trop de détails.
Ça veut dire que tu dois répondre un tout petit peu, mais pas trop.
Ils réussissent à te faire douter.
On peut te donner une fausse information sur toi,
Et elle est vraiment pertinente.
Mais qui réussie ça te mettre le doute sur toi même en fait.
Pour Stan, les dés sont désormais jetés.
Quand c'est physique, là ça dépend de nous.
Tu sais que tu dois courir.
Tu sais que si ça ne va pas, tu dois insister.
Mais quand ça ne dépend pas de nous, c'est un peu stressant.
C'est vrai que c'est un peu frustrant,
De se dire qu'on a pas le pouvoir,
De ce qui peut nous arriver.
On ne sait pas sur quoi on va nous juger,
On ne sait pas comment ça va se faire et donc,
On stresse un peu.
On espère que ça va marcher.
Pour l'instant, moi, mon travail, c'est de rester là.
Quand ça sonne, je cours !
J'ai juste une seule mission,
Je reste là.
Quand ça sonne, je cours !
La sirène retentit de nouveau.
Plusieurs fois par jour,
Les candidats doivent rejoindre la place d'appel au pas de course.
Ici, chaque moment est chronométré.
Même la douche.
Vous avez une minute chacun pour prendre votre douche.
C'est génial !
Après le repas, c'est vraiment le meilleur moment de la journée.
Mais les recrues n'ont pas le temps de savourer.
Extinction des feux, il est 22h.
Demain, la journée s'annonce décisive.
C'est maintenant au tour de tous les volontaires,
D'être fixés sur leur sort.
Ce matin, c'est la proclamation des résultats.
L'annonce sera faite par le patron du centre,
Le lieutenant Sébastien.
Pour tous ces hommes,
Des semaines d'efforts vont elles être récompensées ?
Un par un, les reçus sont appelés par le lieutenant.
Stan commence à réaliser,
Les noms défilent et pour lui, l'échec se profile.
Malgré toute sa bonne volonté et ses qualités physiques,
Le jeune Gabonais ne rejoindra pas la Légion étrangère.
Idem pour Swann l'Ecossais.
Son nom n'est pas prononcé.
Lui non plus ne sera pas légionnaire.
Parmi les sélectionnés qui restent en course,
Kovick, l'ancien prof ukrainien, voit son rêve se réaliser.
À partir de maintenant,
Il fait officiellement partie de l'armée française.
Vous êtes tous sélectionnés.
Mais si quelqu'un parmi vous, n'est pas prêt à accepter ce choix,
Il faut le dire maintenant !
Tout de suite, ne perdez pas de temps !
Ni le votre, ni le mien !
Donc je vous demande encore une fois.
Est-ce que quelqu'un veut partir ?
À cette seconde, la vie de Wesley, l'Américain,
Et de tous les autres retenus,
Vient de basculer.
Au moindre écart de conduite, la sanction est immédiate.
La seule faute de ce jeune Russe,
Ne pas avoir répondu assez vite à l'appel de son nom.
Kovick et les nouveaux légionnaires,
Sont désormais prévenu,
Il faut obéir et réagir immédiatement.
Même pour les tâches les plus banales.
Ici, ils doivent déposer leur paquetage dans leur chambrée,
Un sprint en moins de 10 secondes.
Dans les semaines qui viennent,
L'apprentissage va se poursuivre à un rythme de plus en plus soutenu.
Au même moment,
Pour les recalés, c'est l'heure du départ.
Vous n'êtes pas sélectionné pour entrer dans les rangs de la Légion étrangère.
Donc à l'appel de votre nom,
Vous allez percevoir le solde que vous allez toucher.
Vous rentrez chez vous.
Tous ces hommes doivent se résigner à abandonner leur rêve.
Maigre consolation, une solde de 40€ par jour depuis leur arrivée à Aubagne.
Pour Stan, c'est un difficile retour à la vie civile.
Le jeune Gabonais retrouve son identité.
Ton passeport, ça correspond ?
Oui.
Ok, prends le.
Stan n'auras pas le droit à une deuxième chance.
Il ne pourra plus jamais se présenter à la Légion.
Est ce qu'on devient insensible à force de s'occuper des gens qui sont éliminés ?
Il n'y a pas de sensibilisation ici.
Insensible, c'est pas possible !
On ne ressent rien.
Stan se préparait mentalement et physiquement depuis des mois.
L'échec est cruel.
Il ne saura jamais pourquoi il n'a pas été retenu.
Inapte définitive.
Mon profil ne correspond pas aux besoins de la Légion étrangère.
Je n'en sait pas plus sincèrement.
Mais je pense que c'est eux les experts, c'est eux qui savent.
S'ils disent que mon profil ne correspond pas,
C'est qu'effectivement cela ne correspond pas.
Je ne suis pas venu ici en tant que touriste.
Je suis venu ici parce que je voulais effectivement faire carrière.
Je voulais travailler ici.
Je voulais me faire une place dans la Légion étrangère.
Maintenant quand on me dit que je suis inapte définitivement,
Oui, je suis quand même déçu.
Stan et cet autre recalé n'ont aucune possibilité,
De tenter à nouveau la sélection.
Dans certains cas, comme par exemple un problème de santé mineur,
Les candidats peuvent se représenter.
Parmi les 56 rescapés de la promotion,
Wesley, il vient du Texas.
Après avoir échoué au test d'entrée des marines américains,
Il est déjà soulagé d'être dans le dernier carré.
J'ai un poids en moins sur mes épaules.
C'est cool.
C'est comme si j'avais gagné à la loterie.
Je suis vraiment content.
Vous savez où vous allez là ?
N'ont aucune idée d'où on va.
On ne se pose pas de questions.
Symbole de leur sélection,
Dans quelques minutes, ils vont recevoir leur paquetage.
On est là pour vous donner les tenues.
Les recrues sont maintenant habillées de pied en cap.
L'uniforme réglementaire est la récompense de plusieurs semaines d'efforts.
Pour célébrer l'instant, encore quelques pompes,
Dans la bonne tradition de la légion.
Merci camarade !
Autre temps fort de leur incorporation,
La coupe réglementaire.
Pour tous,
Passage à la tondeuse.
Pour Kovick, l'ukrainien,
Sans doute le moment le plus difficile depuis son arrivée à la Légion.
Mais je n'ai pas changé de coupe de cheveux depuis le CM2.
Oh là là, ça fait beaucoup.
Voilà, c'est terminé !
Regarde toi.
C'est horrible. Ça ne me plait pas du tout.
Ça ne te plait pas ?
Non, vraiment pas.
Tu réalises que c'est pour toute ta vie ?
Ouais, mais je n'y peux rien,
C'est ma nouvelle vie.
Hope est sud africain, c'est un ancien garde du corps.
Il a encore du mal à réaliser qu'il a réussi.
J'ai vraiment eu peur car ils nous ont appelés par ordre alphabétique.
Et quand est venue la lettre H,
Je n'ai pas tout de suite entendu mon nom.
Je me suis dit Wow, qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ?
Je me voyais déjà reprendre l'avion pour rentrer chez moi.
Comment j'allais trouver un autre boulot.
Et enfin après 5 ou 6 noms,
Ils ont quand même dit mon nom.
Et là, j'étais vraiment soulagé.
Ça fait plaisir à entendre.
C'est bon, je peux y aller ?
À Aubagne, dernier réveil au clairon,
Pour les nouveaux légionnaires.
À l'aube, ils sont convoqués pour une cérémonie officielle,
Dirigée par le lieutenant Sébastien.
Les reçus sont officiellement engagés par la Légion.
Engagé volontaire !
Tour à tour, chacun reçoit son contrat.
Hop, le Sud-Africain.
Engagé volontaire !
Kovick, l'Ukrainien.
Et Wesley, le Texan.
Engagé volontaire !
Civiles il y a encore quelques semaines,
Ces hommes ont déjà parcouru un long chemin,
Depuis le fort de Nogent.
Ils sont 56 aujourd'hui à s'engager pour le corps d'élite,
Qui les a fait rêver.
À Castelnaudary, dans le Sud-Ouest,
Ils vont découvrir pleinement leur nouveau monde.
À commencer par l'adjudant Stéphane, le chef de l'instruction.
Il est allemand,
Ancien parachutiste, il a servi sur tous les fronts.
Son expérience du terrain fait de lui,
Un des instructeurs les plus respectés de la Légion.
Asseyez-vous maintenant. Assis, assis !
Les légionnaires vont vite être fixés,
Sur le sens de la discipline de leur nouveau chef.
Arrête de dormir, arrête de dormir !
Ça fait 1 minute que t'es dans le bus, tu dors déjà.
Le prochain qui dort, il va débarquer.
Il va marcher avec le caporal chef.
Il adore marcher.
On y va progressivement.
Là c'est fini fort Nogent, c'est fini Aubagne.
Là, on tape dans le bois dur !
À l'armée on donne des ordres, on ne chouchoute pas.
À partir de maintenant,
Les règles vont radicalement changer.
Rapidement !
Nouvelles règles, mais aussi nouveaux lieux.
Les futurs légionnaires,
Prennent leurs quartiers à quelques kilomètres de Castelnaudary.
Dans une ferme restaurée par l'armée.
En pleine campagne,
Coupés du monde extérieur,
Ils ont un mois pour se plier au code strict de la Légion.
Vous avez 4 minutes pour récupérer votre gobelet.
C'est parti. On y va !
Sous les ordres du sergent Oleg,
Les engagés volontaires s'exécutent pour chaque tâche demandée,
La plus minime soit elle.
Comme ici,
Récupérer son gobelet dans son barda.
À peine arrivés, ils sont soumis à une pression de tous les instants.
Chacune de leurs actions est scrupuleusement observée,
Et évaluée par les instructeurs.
Dorénavant, les ordres se succèdent sans logique particulière.
Ici, plus le temps de se poser la moindre question,
Il faut obéir au doigt et à l'œil.
Les nouvelles recrues découvrent sans plus tarder leur nouvel univers.
En silence, direction les dortoirs.
Une chambrée pour 16 hommes.
Pour chacun, un espace minuscule,
Qu'il faut organiser avec la plus grande rigueur possible.
Les engagés volontaires ont exactement 5 minutes,
Pour s'installer dans les règles.
À qui appartient cette armoire ici ?
Voilà, ça, c'est les petits détails.
Tu vois la différence ?
Juan Antonio est chilien.
Très motivé par sa nouvelle vie,
Il est prêt à tout accepter pour devenir légionnaire.
Ça fait partie du boulot.
Tu dois savoir travailler sous la pression et encore plus ici.
Parce que la Légion, c'est une troupe d'élite.
Tu dois travailler sous pression tout le temps et bien le faire.
Ça fait partie de l'entraînement.
Tu as deux options.
Tu prends tout ça comme une punition ou tu prends ça comme de l'entraînement.
Mais moi, en tout cas, j'aime ça.
Très rapidement, Juan Antonio, qui était employé de banque,
Sort du lot.
Tu donnes un coup de main à ton camarade ?
C'est bien ça !
C'est la cohésion.
Regarde là-bas, il y a une différence, non ?
Oui, Sergent.
Qu'est-ce qui est derrière là ?
Plis correctement ta veste.
Cyril est français,
À 30 ans, il veut réaliser son rêve,
Entrer dans la Légion.
J'étais sapeur pompier, mais c'est pas du tout la même chose.
Là c'est beaucoup plus rapide, beaucoup plus petit,
Beaucoup plus carré aussi.
Une nouvelle aventure.
Un changement de vie radical.
Il faut abandonner sa famille, ses Amis, son ancien boulot,
Ce n'est pas évident, mais moi, je l'ai fait et je ne regrette pas.
Cyril a un avantage sur les autres futurs légionnaires.
C'est un des seuls francophones de la promotion.
Camarade, présente toi.
Non, je ne comprends pas.
Présente toi.
Pour la plupart, ne pas bien parler français devient un problème au quotidien.
Problème pour Wesley, l'Américain,
Comme pour tous les autres,
À partir de maintenant, tous les ordres se donnent en français.
Je vous ai montré comment vous faites votre armoire.
Tous les jours, tous les jours, tous les jours, tous les jours,
Je vais vérifier.
Je passerais la revue tous les matins.
Donc il faut que ce soit pareil.
Compris ou pas ?
Oui Sergent !
Le quotidien à la caserne, c'est aussi les corvées.
Pas forcément la raison pour laquelle tous ces hommes veulent s'engager.
Pour Cyril, l'ancien pompier et Juan Antonio, le Sud américain,
Au programme aujourd'hui, le nettoyage de la salle de bain des instructeurs.
Mon dernier travail était dans une banque d'entreprise.
J'y ai passé 3 ans.
Un jour, j'ai réalisé que ma vie était loin devant mes yeux,
Juste assis devant un ordinateur.
Rien d'excitant, pas d'aventures.
Alors j'ai décidé de venir ici.
Je garde toujours en tête mon objectif.
Je garde aussi en tête que la personne la plus importante de ma vie, c'est ma mère.
Elle croit en moi, donc je ne peux pas échouer.
Je lui ai fait une promesse, donc je vais la tenir.
Vous pouvez la voir ici, elle est toujours avec moi.
Alors toutes les fois où je suis fatigué, je la regarde.
Retour au terrain.
Pour une fois, on ne demande pas à ses hommes de courir, mais de marcher au pas.
Et dans une cadence propre à la Légion,
Plus lente que celle des autres régiments.
C'est une tradition qui perdure depuis sa création en 1831.
Chaque jour, les engagés répètent les chants qui forgent l'unité du corps d'élite.
Autre spécialité, le parcours du combattant.
Pour cette partie de l'instruction, il retrouve le sergent Oleg.
Aujourd'hui, vous allez faire un parcours complet.
Il faut faire attention parce que ça glisse,
Sur certains obstacles, ça glisse.
Faites attention, sécurité, c'est prioritaire.
Question ?
OK, on va passer aux obstacles.
Il faut un chrono de trois minutes 30 maximum.
Si c'est plus, ce n'est pas bon.
C'est dur ?
C'est très dur, c'est très dur !
C'est un des exercices les plus difficile à la Légion.
Technique, sécurité.
Aller plus vite,  plus vite, plus vite !
C'est bien, c'est bien, c'est bien !
Bravo.
Marche et ne t'assoies pas.
C'est bien, c'est bien, c'est très bien !
Respirez.
C'est facile !
Non, c'est beaucoup de travail pour faire ça.
Tous ont réussi le parcours avec succès,
Mais le chemin est encore long,
Avant de pouvoir porter fièrement le képi blanc,
Le symbole de leur entrée dans la grande famille de la Légion.
Les engagés devront aller jusqu'au bout de toutes les épreuves à venir.